it was the first long-awaited public
statement by the founder and leader of
the shin chon Jeter CH Lehmann he
prostrated himself before journalists to
say sorry I don't know how to apologize
to the Korean people I extend my deepest
regret it wasn't intentional
we had many new infections that we
couldn't stop the outbreak in South
Korea has cast new scrutiny on the
church at the center of it seen by many
Christians as a secretive sect and
turned the spotlight on its Messiah like
leader who calls himself the promised
prophet ki dr. Tehran please MA it may
appear Christian but it's actually
different with a different doctrine and
system they revere le monde he like
jesus li duk-soo is a counselor who
helps former followers of shin chon ji
such as an soo young who described the
crowded conditions inside a typical
church gathering a man hey Han
incredible huh cool you would be 5
centimeters away from the next person
and you would have to say Amen after
every sentence the pastor speaks it's
the best environment for the virus to
spread all of the shin chon Jeeter
chah's have been closed and some have
been attacked an online petition
demanding the group's disbandment has
well over a million signatures some
local leaders have called for Shin Chon
G's elders to be investigated for
possible homicide and for hiding the
identities of some of its estimated
quarter of a million members Shin Chon
ji says it's being unfairly persecuted
and health officials have warned against
driving the organization further
underground that would make the tackling
of this outbreak harder
Himba none the government has done a lot
to contain this and we will do
everything we can to support that effort
but the shin yongjae church still
insists it has suffered the most with
its members making up more than half of
all the confirmed cases in South Korea
Rob McBride al Jazeera Seoul